[Musique]
isabelle est ce que le théâtre c'est une
vocation
si la vocation c'est la certitude
sûrement pas j'étais très attiré par le
théâtre mais seulement dans la lecture
des pièces que j'ai pu faire depuis que
je suis au lycée
donc je mis les pieds dans un théâtre
assez tard cet art pour quelqu'un qui
aurait eu une vocation très très affirmé
une façon précoce
j'étais au théâtre la première fois en
14 min et puis c'est donc une suite de
maillon d'une chaîne qui s'est formée
indépendamment de la volonté et qui fait
maintenant je suis aux français c'est à
dire que j'aime auxquels on s'attache
parce qu'on finit toujours en fini moi
je commence par mme attachés aux lieux
puis je laime gêne la salle j'aime les
fauteuils j'aime et lumière j'aime les
cariatides tiennent peut-être sur msdn
12h qu'il ya sur la scène j'aime les
choses qui sont qui sont très très
proches de moi je suis heureuse moi je
suis dans une troupe
j'ai des rapports formidable parce que
tous les gens avec lesquels je travaille
pour l'instant ce sont des gens que
j'aime que j'admire et je crois que
d'admiration
cet départ de tous les rapports d'amitié
tout les connivences possible
[Musique]